[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Park Slope Brooklyn where I'm
joined by Mike and Josh Greenfield you
might know them as the brothers green
where week over week these culinary
MacGyver's school you on cheap eats
kitchen hacks and how to recreate your
favorite fast food dishes you have a
couple of components you can make a
cheesy gordita crunch you can make the
Mexican pizza because they're all just
like a little bit of this today we're
keeping it simple stupid
we're exploring the age-old celebrated
late-night snack the midnight munchies
and we're going to and very much
brothers green fashion it's going to be
five ingredients per meal you cannot
[ __ ] it up even if you try they're easy
they're simple and most importantly
they're delicious you can be [ __ ] up
and still not [ __ ] that good this
recipe is a PB&J french toast love it
already
and it is incredible because you can eat
it like a sandwich and that's what I
really love about it we're using challah
bread you want a full piece of bread
because this is going to be a nice thick
piece that we're gonna cut just like
that because we have to stuff some stuff
in there and I'm gonna make a little
incision how do you do it with fluff
like marshmallow fluff stuff or you
could throw marshmallows right in there
chocolate chips they're really you're
only limited by your imagination when it
comes to the midnight munchies yeah yeah
one guy packing this thing got another
friend packing a bowl I do like to kind
of push off the seam so it's a little
more clean on the outside
and then just make sure that bread soaks
in that egg butter oil I mean butters
delicious but what ever kind of oil you
got doesn't matter
have is there anything you do make like
everyone's got something in their
repertoire maybe it's just peanut butter
and jelly I mean yeah make a mean cereal
I make a mean cereal I love that yeah
but you know that's the point of a
recipe like this if you make peanut
butter and jelly we're just taking it
one notch above that
it smells like french toast with a
little butter burn action and that's how
you know that's how you know you're
getting to the good stuff and the funny
thing about butter burning is butter
butter burning a bed.but butter browning
is actually more flavor so that's not
the end of the world this is one of my
favorite parts about cooking is you can
take something very simple and you can
make it look very fancy by just a little
plating action so I just drizzle on a
little bit of maple syrup and then the
coolest part about this thing is you
don't need a fork and knife especially
late night come on we're going straight
in sandwich style Josh you don't get one
I got a piece all right well I get
Canada's own work so much better than a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich and
it's so much better than french toast
why yeah there's no one think to just
make this a brunch staple just realize I
don't know why all these years we should
put the jelly in first and the peanut
butter said why cuz it's low leakage
if you nut butter seals it overnight
all right so up next we have the buffalo
chicken pizza this is a hot ones collab
you can say we wanted to incorporate the
good stuff right here we've got your
finer size you guys up you guys you
think that extra mile like so when I
first moved here and I was kind of
challenging myself to eat like you know
$20 a week whatever was I'd buy thing a
flatbread some tomato sauce some cheese
maybe some pepperoni if I like did well
that way
every meal I would cook them right on
the flattop while I throw em in the oven
you can make these personal pizzas and
minutes so what we're gonna do first is
make a buffalo sauce we've got the hot
ones so we're gonna do equal parts
butter Josh why don't you add equal
parts hot sauce the you got to watch out
for that so what we're doing here is
just emulsifying these two together so
if you have you ever been in a bar and
you've got some separated buffalo sauce
they didn't put in the effort to just
whisk it who are the multiplying at 3:00
in the morning
why don't you chop up some of those
fingers like slice yes perfect so here's
the thing I used to do this trick a lot
of times where I'd have frozen pizza or
frozen nuggets and it's kind of like do
I do the microwave or do I do the oven
what I do is I microwave them first for
like 30 seconds to get them soft then
pop them in the oven so you can get
crispy so we're gonna coat these guys
that's what makes it buffalo chicken
right there so a lot of people are gonna
be mad because you know the pizza has no
cheese on I was gonna say that from the
ingredients that seemed to be missing an
important one but it does have blue
cheese so we go we're getting a box
there there is there is a cheese product
so that's the whole thing about this is
you could literally make any toppings
that you want you can do a barbecue
chicken pizza with mozzarella pop your
sauce and chicken the amazing there you
go you're cooking you feel like I feel
like a Michelin star chef right now
I found that red onion works really
great to kind of cut through a lot of
that intense spice you can throw that in
a pan and just get that crispy on the
bottom that works or you can throw it at
it in an oven at like 400 degrees and
the bottom should get super crispy
coming in hot Wow we got a swap in I
feel like I'm on Rachael Ray
it's a little drizzle yeah a little
green to it you don't have
yeah you know you're working with colors
you're working with flavors garnish it's
always nice to add a little love to it
check out just from thrown in the oven I
mean look at that bottom how long do you
let this cook for that was about 10
minutes in a 400-degree oven and it
looks like you know that looks like
California Pizza Kitchen right it does
and there you go that is our buffalo
chicken flatbread pizza whatever you
want to call it the blue cheese action
is actually key on this that's what's
that's what's driving the Train this is
a dorm room game changer but I also
think you know what this does this makes
you a hero when you make pizzas for
everybody you're a hero
so this is our hacked ramen ramen is a
perfect introduction to upping your game
just a little bit it's like we're
starting with the basics the noodles you
can add just a few elements and make it
awesome so the first thing you do is you
take an egg and this is optional but
it's kind of a cool trick pop it in some
like nice hot and almost boiling water
the egg is gonna cook and kind of simmer
for about 6 minutes then we're just
gonna build a broth in here so you can
start adding whatever you got I got some
miso fermented soy beans delicious and
it's gonna add so much flavor if you
just have miso and water you've got a
very basic miso soup for the people
intimidated by this one is there a more
simple version absolutely it's just
avoiding the egg so you can just throw
the noodles in with some water and then
just start adding your vegetables adding
your spices and like just coming up with
grape froth so by the time the ramen is
cooked in three minutes
you've got like soy sauce in there
you've got chili and you know whatever
you want oh yeah so how long are we
keeping that egg in there the egg will
probably be in there for like six ish
minutes I'd say what do you think yeah
six minutes I mean to boil an egg
properly takes about 12 minutes so the
idea is were half boiling the egg so the
yolk is still runny
alright so egg is done this is coming
out at about 6 minutes and I would get
that right into some cold water and let
it you want to stock out other cooking
so it doesn't overcook you want that egg
runny we got the noodles in there and
we'll let that chill for a minute it
takes what like a minute or two to cook
you don't want to overcook them I've
made that mistake on YouTube overcooking
ramen noodles boy do you get it in the
cable of this oh my god we killed his
egg carefully very gently feel it you'll
notice it's not fully it's fully cooked
but it's not fully hard there's that
means there's some action in here a lot
of money action yeah I'm gonna carefully
unless you feel like your skills are
ready to go cut this egg you think you
got it so what you're gonna do it you
got it look at it alright so you're
gonna slice it right down the middle
look at that oh that's how you make a
sit in there just kind of go like that
yes my man and the best part about this
egg is you want to get that mixed in
because now you are adding this
creaminess of the yolk completely
altering the flavor of the brah
slurp a bowl has got this flip oh nice
perfection you know we're not using meat
in this dish but it does have a meaty
quality to it
yeah this is a mushroom action from a 99
cent ramen packet to that with a few
extra ingredients
we're [ __ ] on basic dorm-room
ramen so we've done a nice range of
Munchie food so far this to me if you
have like 10 seconds and you just want
to eat is the ultimate cereal so I take
frozen blueberries mango you can use
like dates or raisins any kind of nut
and some coconut this is kind of like
clear your pantry out cereal clear you
pick any changes colors to just kind of
throw some blueberries in which the
scoop is they'll help keep the milk
super cold some fresh mango any kind of
nut you have I got peanuts Chuck some
dates in Co this is coconut milk and
it's thick so you don't need that too
much and then you can add in some water
and you want to just kind of mix that
around a little bit look color change
water change and what's cool is if the
fruit is really cold it'll kind of
solidify with like the liquid a little
bit and what else is cool if you're high
you've got color-changing cereal oh
that's cool - pretty much every meal
that we've made today if somebody were
to look at it they'd be like oh look at
these adult men acting like 12 year old
but this is actually kind of grown-up
until you do this I mean this is lowness
we've destroyed your whole concept this
isn't no here's the thing so before when
I used to do you know any kind of cereal
I found the scoop of ice cream would
make it cold as it melts it kind of adds
it's a nice cool liquid
Cheers wait wait wait should we get some
hot
donar the first thing that comes in mind
that's like sensory overload gas so
refreshing and actually this came
because I didn't have any money I didn't
afford to get cereal so I had something
I had like powdered milk one day and I
had all these things around like nuts
and stuff and no lighter shop this came
cuz you were stoned you trying to either
go to that
[Music]